始め
どうやってをもずにしたん
こんにちははじめそうです7月になりまし
た皆さん新生活始まっている方たくさん
いらっしゃると思います新しい学校新しい
お仕事新しい環境何がを卒業したなんか
いろんなことの切り替えの4月と言われて
ますけども私ジムシャツを大学を卒業して
も6年経って6年 youtube だけ
やってるわけなんですけど大新生活
ないんですねえもう私の船が新生活という
ものはじゃっていない寂しい悲しいちん
生活のあの何か新しいことが始まるらの
感覚がないんだ加工新しい何かを始めたい
と有機物がちょっと出てきましたので今回
の動画では私学校に行ってきます入学で
入学新しい学校に行ってきますそう
u 2 u 2部の学校に行ってきますで
私はずメスと皆様のおかげですね去年
2021年は12月でチャンネル登録者数
が1000万人超えて
カーチャンネル登録お願いします
1000万に行ったんですけどもまだまだ
まだまだまだまだ俺はそんな大したもの
ないです自分より頑張ってたりすごい
ユーチューバーさんと繰り出すがたくさん
いるから全然そんな対しターン
ものではないですけどそういう気持ち的に
はもう-1000万人の状態でゼロみたい
な感覚でやろうかなと思ってて書士妖精
ちゃダメなんですよどんなときもいつでも
彼だある金は使います動画に所詮初心者年
逆に4綾子として10年目ですよね
youtube 行ってきたはずみ社長が
youtube の知識とかあると思うん
ですけども全然まだ学べることだが知ら
ないこととかならわからないことだらけだ
と思うんですよ6掛けてここまで来たわけ
ですしてユーチューバーという言葉が無い
時代から youtube やってるから
逆にそういう youtube の学校と
があるじゃん歳って youtube を
育てる学校とか全然何をせてるんだろう
っていうか逆に大丈夫それ大丈夫な今日は
実際に私はせるした長身に帰ってを
youtube の方何おりません
youtube ってない今日1日
youtube の格好に体験入学して
youtube というものを学んでいき
たいと思います先生には多大な
プレッシャーをおかけします妄想はござい
ませんではそろそろ入っています
福られないか心配だか
あみあみ
さあもなく学校に行きます遅刻した体で
入ってみようと思います今日弾み社長では
なくゼロから10チューブを学ぶして枝
始めとして言っていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
はいじゃあ次回になったので初めて行き
たいと思います今回の授業のテーマとして
は最も気をちゃんねる運営で大切なので
応援だーをセーバーをしません9
道に迷っちゃってって
amaran
kazu kane
軽症を負った出演書等を持ってまた次の
ことではない
みんなんね
今回の授業で学べることっていうところな
んですけど将来がいいなりたいですかって
いうことで触手で言うという千葉になり
たいというところとあとは動画編集者
なきゃいいよって言うかアティレじゃない
というとはそれかはそれ以外の一手は
いろいろいるかなと思うんですけど
じゃあちょっとみんなに聞いていきたいと
思うんですけど
将来クリエイターになるために頑張ってる
よっていう人かで買えますか
はいインターハイでは動画編集者になり
たいんでした
大変レーザーになりたいと言うとめっちゃ
大
ところでは皆されたらやりたいことって
いっぱいあると思うんですけどどの職種に
なるにしても youtube チャンネル
を伸ばした経験形のないならないよって
いうところお話をしたいと思います
[音楽]
自分が言う中で寝るくるして自分で考えて
釣った魔道はをは視聴者に価値を提供して
その対価としてお金をもらって実際に入金
されるはです中で仕事の全体像カプッと
いうことをみんなをでやれるのが you
[音楽]
donedo の触診になりたい人いら
ないたものは変わらないと思うんですけど
どの職種になる人も youtube
チャンネルをきちんと作っていくっていう
のは無駄にならないよということを抑えて
おりてほしいです
p ジャンパー
7年間
仕事市場ブローチとして活字目を覚めて
から言ってみたんでもやりましょう話しさ
れたと思いますがねえ youtube
チャンネルを伸ばすため日常塗ってきた方
がいいと思いますかペアー競射でいき
ましょうかこうだと思う人みたい
護衛隊です
ブーブー
[音楽]
言っ
にょやっぱり人気のコンテンツとか今
流行っているとインドのものとかあると
思うんですけれども分析することによって
それが見てもらう入り口になりやすい関連
動画に上がったりだとか
自分のチャンネルに来てもらえる入り靴を
大きくするためには市場分析は必要なのか
なと思います大
あれはみんな言ってもらったものを全部
世界かなと思うんですけどもうちょっと
抽象ぞ高くすると努力を無駄にしない為
っていうところが大きいかなぁと思います
と最初は絶対も youtube で
チャンネル伸ばしてやろうと角膜いこうと
か色々モチベーション高くやってるんです
けどそれが何か間違った方向製品努力し
ちゃうと血管ってちょっと残酷だけどてな
いっていうのありません
[音楽]
これから努力をするのはもちろん大事だし
いいことなんですけど努力する方向性を
ミスるとなかなかチャンネルってうまく
いっただー必要というのがこれ結構現実的
なところだと思いますたんでせっかく
頑張ろうっていうはすごいいい気持ちが
あるんだとしたらちょっと正しい方向性で
努力して自分が欲しい結果をとるっていい
と思いますそれをやるための方が
ファーストステップというのがは市場分析
っているのでこれが珍島を市場分析して
勝ち筋をきちんと定めて youtube
チャンネルを運営してくれるかなと思って
おります次に者ジャンル選定の話のところ
で何々をもおっしゃって聞いたことあり
ますか中ブルーオーシャンとかレッド
おっしゃるとかから聞いたことある人って
いうことですか
イラクの食べよう true
んですよあるあーやさんにあります
ちなみにディアブルーおっしゃってる
こんな感じです
とブルー王さんは
競争のない未開拓市場のことです重低音
ですねぜアイレットをおっしゃってるんだ
なんです
鉄塔さんは家れ血を洗う
今日の
編 to do かもう
競争率が高い場所でしょうか
朝
[音楽]
クッキー
阿蘇
多かっにぞ参加するっていう方法もあり
ます苛烈な競争列島三平とこで代表綺麗な
ジャベ上げてないんですけどここは結構
競争厳しかったりする人はこうをはそれ
こそ enter mission
芸能人の方々もみつめて入った渡会レベル
はなっていて
じゃあこの猫もちゃんならどう戦っていく
かというボージャンの細分化するって言う
やる方が再演背高かったりします例えば1
本を上げ目市場や国有マークの鮎師ゾンビ
u とめちゃくちゃレップ王者なんです
けどそれを細分化して大変がされたところ
での発言者さんが来て横が当たり名声高く
行けたりしますと例えばしたことにアニメ
市場といっても細胞化するとアニメの考察
だとかまたお勧めのアニメを紹介して
くれるあとはアニメのでびゅーぐっという
ところがあったりしますこのように
ジャンルを細胞化して再評価されたところ
が反応で戦うっていうのが明け貼ったりし
ますの負担でどこまで目指すかっていう
ことでいうと自分の達成したい
知名度がほしいとは広告収益が欲しいとか
の自分の目的が達成できるキャンプのかて
晴れだったり市場中盤のところで戦って
いくのかいいじゃないかなと思います姉と
じゃあその市城之堀を張ってどうやって
調べればいいのっていう話になると思うん
ですけどこういう2を入れたりしてました
きっと iq っていうのと考えとる
かっていうのが有名どころかなと思います
と
でこのビッグ iq 体の温か市場競合
チャンネルがどういう水で成長してきたの
かとかそれで面白い
札を強く入れてる40どれくらい
ほぼ全員入れてますねはいっ
の感じは過ぎて行きたいと思います彼は
いろいろ様子を浴びたんですけどそういう
ことでいうと jal とかスネークして
勝つ準備をすればチャンネルが伸びるのが
偶然から自然に変わりますよっていう
ところがこういうこともガザを受け考え
綺麗だったりしますと
[音楽]
ん
ってな感じなんでこの価値の創造とたちの
原発のところを実際グループワークでやっ
てもらいたいなぁと思います
お題がこれです自分の誕生日会に1万人
集める食べましたと考えてください予算の
制約はありませんおおに触れなければ何を
しても大丈夫です実現可能性は考えなくて
ok
n 自分の誕生日会に一番に集めるための
策を考えてくださいチェーンわけなんです
けどそしたら者この島からこっち
余裕ですくん
今に集めるんですので言いません
俺もそれ思ったんだけど予算がないんで
それじゃないから4
日して持っている
アジアミニこれ施策でニューエイジを招待
するとかだった場合その人のフォロワー数
が分くらいだから集まりと譜面とかそう
いうところの話もできるようにお願いし
ます
そうねそう次期 macbook pro
もらえるんだったら悪い気がします
可能性だった三角直樹食べたいですよね
連結したよかったの世界の場所に勝つを
つけると感じた
今
存在は
利益はを止めなくていいんですよね
家つい見返りを求めてしまいます
リク増強名増加数だという
400m 酵素のど真ん中によろしくね
地域を受けます読めばいい巻くとガール
デーと j で参加してみたいなという
レベルの人は
それと同じような感じですねいろいろね
自分の老いたことだ目指すするんですけど
物で釣ると参加しするだけでものもらって
初回2人が果たしてそのディズニーランド
の輸出に入って
遊ぶだけ遊んで祝ってくれないみたいな形
で退場議会なのかどうかっていう自分が
ちょっと生まれてきますね
の作り線とたちを追って
dj 1セットずつ弄ってくれよねー
グリス伏せ0お前ています対策
それぞれで一番個分のでっかいホール事業
はいえ作ってもらいましたん
という住んでラーズのために進む
じゃあ長打30になったんね
発表してもらいたいと思うんですけど
みんなパパの空ないはまとまりましたが
内容ですか山倉の方よろしくお願いします
いい
し
う
我々の
水部はに
ランド水を加速化し気にしてごらん程度の
集客を1本ずつプレイも来てもありますで
一番ごめんのホールゲージのおむつ用
インフレラーズ大人びたてましてただいい
パックもあるのででき名を刻むかと思い
ますんでミラコスタも止まれるよう
交通費を全部知っている立っていたけれど
も来てもらうためにより香木を打たなけれ
ばよね思います tech トップチビ
あの連合近眼香水せて乗せるなど集客
同じますディズニーシーの最後のパレード
ではポール型金のお家鍋で那須川転身と健
の結末が見られる最高のイベントに一番に
来ると思います
[音楽]
終わりですね ani
それでねの授業な弱いのになるんで終わり
にしたいと思いますみなさんおつかれさま
でしたん
[音楽]
voodoo
haibane
ん
[音楽]
bl